le principe c'est de se déplacer pour
ceux qui ne pourraient pas le faire
on a demandé à monsieur paré de
s'assurer avec les organismes
communautaires de tenir compte de
l'inscription des gens pour être sûr
qu'on va contacter nos organismes
communautaires qui pourraient
accompagner les gens mais le principe
ceux qui doivent se déplacer s'est faite
hier lors du point de presse mais à bien
des personnes âgées qui ne vivent pas en
résidence pour qu'ils se déplacer dans
un centre de vaccination est très très
difficile sinon impossible on a
plusieurs courriels de téléspectateurs
de citoyens qui en témoignent ils sont
un peu inquiet ce nom désemparés dans la
situation donc pas question de
vaccination domicile ici au québec pour
le moment pourtant dans le canton de
vaud en suisse
une initiative permet depuis lundi
dernier le 15 février de vacciner à
domicile les personnes les plus
vulnérables qui ne peuvent pas se
déplacer un projet dont on pourrait
éventuellement s'inspirer pourquoi pas
après j'en ai parlé plus tôt aujourd'hui
avec susana garcia directrice générale
de l'association vaudoise des dés de
soins à domicile
une association qui est dédié justement
aux soins domicile depuis près de 50 ans
bram garcia bonsoir depuis lozinghem de
24,60 ben ça alors votre association
emploie plus de 5000 personnes vous est
dédié aux soins à domicile notamment des
personnes âgées comment arrivez-vous à
vacciner les personnes âgées à domicile
avec ce fameux vaccin fire dont on nous
dit ici qu'on ne peut pas le faire à
domicile
alors c'est une organisation assez
importante à mettre en place bien sûr il
ya les conditions de sécurité
d'utilisation de transport de ce vaccin
qui ont dû être conçus vous travaillez
avec nos équipes mais c'est vrai qu'on a
une grande tradition d'aller à domicile
donc on s'est tourné essentiellement
vers les personnes qui nous font
confiance qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
déplacer et on travaille en étroite
collaboration avec la force qui a été
mise en place dans le cadre vous et donc
les centres de vaccination prépare les
vaccins et nous les transportant dans
des conditions de sécurité importantes
et puis à partir de là est le territoire
vaudois est peut-être moins grand que
votre territoire
nous organisons nos tournées en six
heures parce que ça c'est aussi une des
conditions d'utilisation de ce vaccin
pour pouvoir procéder aux injections de
cécile de ses silos voilà pendant que je
vous parle on voit quelqu'un qui porte
un sac sans doute eu réfrigérée comment
arrive-t-on à préserver le vaccin
pendant le transport et jusqu'à c'était
ce retour dans le bras du paseo d'un
patient alors oui tout est extrêmement
chronométrie parce qu'on sait que des
moments où on prépare les seringue
on a six heures pour les gobelets les
injecter donc les centres de vaccination
sont organisées nous arrivons sur place
avec mon véhicule nous chargeons les
vaccins dans ces boîtes que vous avez lu
réfrigérée qui ont d'ailleurs été
travaillé pour cette occasion là à
l'intérieur on a de quoi entreposer ces
vaccins pour qu'il soit vraiment
immobilisé et qui bouge moins possible
dans des conditions aussi de
réfrigération autres cadres de fraîcheur
qui les maintient et à partir de là nous
avons détourné qui sont déjà organisés
pain dit fier des rendez-vous qui sont
fixés et nous travaillons à 2 p une des
particularités c'est qu'une rock le
vaccin est fait il faut un temps
d'observation à zurich a pas de réaction
allergique elle dit malheureusement une
réaction devait avoir lieu ce qui n'a
pas été le cas jusqu'à présent et c'est
très rare mais malgré ça on a un petit
dur
son numéro d'urgence on travaille avec
les médecins aussi un traiteur est l'une
des deux personnes
le reste est l autre continuer la
tournée ça veut dire qu'en swan l'acte
de la vaccination
nos collaborateurs qui sont dix
soignants qui ont l'habitude de faire
des vaccins
c'est pas ça le plus important le plus
important c'est toute la préparation en
amont et cette logistique cet
enchaînement en fait d'actes qui permet
de tenir le délai est de délivrer un
maximum de vaccins on ne sait jamais pu
sembler vous avez réussi à cibler les
personnes les plus vulnérables qui ne
pouvaient pas se déplacer dans les sites
de vaccination des personnes les plus
âgées vous comptez vacciner combien de
personnes à terme puisque jusqu'à
maintenant depuis le 15 février
je vois que vous avez vacciner plus de
1700 alors on va en vacciner jusqu'à
1700 ça c'est les personnes qui font
confiance aux centres médicaux sociaux
dans ce canton et qu'on a pu identifier
parce qu'on les connaît parce qu'on a pu
prendre contact avec eux mais il ya
d'autres personnes chez qui nous
n'allons pas qui sont confrontés à la
même situation la même difficulté du
déplacement et le canton donc l'état est
en train de répertorier ces personnes là
on va poursuivre cette vaccination ans
et il semblerait que c'est assez peu de
personnes donc en tout on va vacciner de
je pense 2000 à 2200 personnes
alors ne pas d'initier en un mois en un
mois on à moi oui non alors à tous le
premier vaccin est le deuxième axe ans
le deuxième la deuxième dose donc à
reprendre dans les meilleurs délais
suivent ou sql des led de respecter vous
pour la deuxième dose entre quatre et
six semaines
quatre à six semaines ce qui est
recommandé par pfizer
est ce que ça vient
josé pour utiliser le mot hypothécaire
ce que ces biens hypothéqués les
ressources que vous avez vous avez les
ressources nécessaires pour arriver à
faire cette opération c'est un troll des
difficultés on a dû s'organiser
évidemment qu'on a dû prioriser on a dû
former un certain nombre de
collaborateurs et les binômes sont
formées d'un infirmier au d'une
infirmière avec un monde de l' essai de
la protection civile je ne sais pas si
vous connaissez
et donc ce sont ces binômes là qui vont
à domicile ce sont vingt trois binômes
pour le canton de vaud donc c'est a donc
très important person médaille il ya
aussi toute une logistique mais on reste
quand même un dispositif très important
de 5000 personnes donc voilà c'est un
effort évidemment c'est une priorisation
c'est un acte important parce que ça
s'inscrit dans une campagne très
volontaire de la part du canton et à
commencer par vacciner les personnes qui
étaient en établissements médico-sociaux
et a ouvert des centres de vaccination
qui sont accessibles ce groupe
yogi terre que sont les 75 ans et plus
les personnes avec des maladies
chroniques importante
et puis maintenant depuis le 15 février
cette volonté d'amener le vaccin à
domicile pour les personnes qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer et qui
évidemment font partie des plus
vulnérables face à ces extraordinaires
vous faut comprendre que c'est vraiment
une priorité chez vous il n'ya pas
d'angle mort en fait les personnes les
plus vulnérables à domicile comptait
parmi vos priorités
voilà c'est une volonté politique de
notre ministre de la santé qui avale a
organisé ses priorités parce
qu'évidemment comme partout d'ailleurs
on est en manque de vaccins donc
évidemment quand il faut il faut
prioriser le rythme de la vaccination de
la population et cette partie de la
population qui en ont ré et
et peu importante au regard de l'onction
de la population mais c'est malgré tout
c'est un qui probablement alors plus
besoin alors si un adversaire merci
beaucoup de l'association vaudoise des
dés de soins à domicile dédiés à cette
clientèle la plus vulnérables de notre
société merci beaucoup madame garcia et
bonne souhaitez-vous merci à vous